a woman stretches after a sleepless
night tucked between razor wire and the
Waters of the Rio Grande she is 26 year
old orianna Escuela a nail salon worker
from Caracas Venezuela who traveled for
two months and waited across the river
from Mexico to reach the U.S side with
her daughter
gesturing to communicate over the noise
of Patrol boats she says her
three-year-old daughter was stung by a
wasp on the eye and she passed the night
pressed to her mother's chest
most of the hundreds of people we
spotted crossing over a period of a few
hours say political persecution and
violence drove them from their homes in
South and Central America
after harrowing Journeys through
Panama's jungle and territories
controlled by criminal gangs they're
stuck on this American Riverbank
exhausted and thirsty they beg U.S
border Patrol boats for help one
eventually agrees and a few women and
children are allowed to board
and her daughter are among the
youngest his pregnant wife in pink
toured another boat but they're told no
they cannot board
as the sun climbs higher the people grow
tired of waiting a few climb over the
wild fence and others follow including
the pregnant woman in pink
we're happy because we achieved our goal
she says she's due to give birth this
week whether her husband and
brother-in-law will still be with her
then is unknown their fate will now be
decided by the U.S government
as more people stream over the razor
wire the moment is emotional for many
families embrace
friends celebrate
some are unable to walk on their own
others collapse
U.S border Patrol agents call for
Medical Aid they've been instructed to
help when lives may be in danger every
time we've seen Federal border patrol
agents cut through this wire to allow a
few people to pass almost immediately
State Agents come back and put up more
razor wire this is indicative of the
political battle between Washington and
these republican-controlled border
states with migrants caught in the
middle
many people have lost their shoes so
their first steps on American soil are
with bare feet
Republican members of Congress who
visited on Monday said they saw an
invasion this is a national security
crisis for our country we have known
terrorists crossing our border
the migrants will have a difficult time
proving they are not security risks and
that they qualify for Asylum the
majority of cases fail and people are
deported
but that is tomorrow's worry they say
today they've arrived Heidi Joe Castro
Al Jazeera Eagle Pass Texas
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera